anytime innocent life is lost as tragic
and very sad Muslims who are the true
followers of Jesus Moses and all of
God's prophets with Muhammad is being
defined on the last condemned these evil
acts and we should all condemn them
wherever they happen be it in Paris
Syria Palestine Burma all innocent life
is precious now don't be selective in
your condemnation because it's not cool
or because you won't fit in if you
condemn one but not all innocent life is
precious we condemn it any time it's
lost Muslims have a genuine altruism
because it's a basic teachings in Islam
and we would probably be the most upset
when we hear such sad news because
Muslims have the most to lose it's very
disheartening when you see ungenerous
and malevolent people who are just
looking to join any hate parade coming
out cursing threatening just augmenting
the fire with their poisonous and toxic
hate these malevolent type of people are
no different and would do no different
than the terrorists themselves have
given the chance you hear them calling
to kill all Muslims vandalizing mosques
houses of worship where people go to
bushes and peace attacking innocent
Muslim women in hijab these are those
treacherous and demonic human beings
these are the real terrorists who are
just waiting to do real terror against
innocent Muslims their threats and
actions are loud but no one seems to
listen no one seems to care or condemn
most of these people who spew this nasty
toxic hate if you look closely are very
arrogant people who already live very
bitter and angry lives probably wouldn't
give a poor man even a dime nor attenti
any neighborly needs nor do they care
what corruption is happening in their
own backyard let alone in Paris or in
other part of the world it's only when I
hate parade is in town via Facebook
Twitter or just to spew that poisonous
hate at any chance they get really think
about how depressing is that to live
that kind of hate filled life now let's
compare that to our role model
the prophet of mercy who was sent to all
of mankind who was consoled by the
crater in the Quran because he was
almost killing himself out of love
worrying with grief because they had
denied the almighty the pure monotheism
of the maker of mankind whose message
was the same as Jesus and all of God's
prophets which was to proclaim God's
oneness and to set up no one else in
worship or have intermediaries next to
the crater of mankind the Quran is very
explicit and clear it tells us when an
innocent life is lost it's as though you
have killed all of mankind this is in
Quran chapter 5 verse 32 but they say
look Isis they're shouting Allahu Akbar
representing you and you guys are not
condemning it I said look my dear
brother what rock you've been under or
hiding in we condemn it very loud and
very clear the problem is you just don't
want to hear it you seem to fit the
description of when Jesus said though
seeing they see not though hearing they
do not understand how many times are we
going to tell you that this has nothing
to do with Islam how many Muslims and
Muslim scholars have we had just for
instance on the Dean show telling the
world the same thing but the media loves
creating sensationalism instead of
giving us a platform and a voice to
educate they instead help prop up and
promote ISIL as if they represent Islam
that 0.01 fringe element that even
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him had
prophesized would come he warned us
Muslims about these ISIL kill more
Muslims if you didn't know that too now
the mainstream media they don't dare
give the spotlight nor advertise them 24
7 wall 2 our coverage groups such as
sovereign state neo-nazis or the KKK
even though these groups are making so
much trouble and are the greatest threat
to America and national security you
don't hear peep just ice so Isis all day
every day programming people day by day
as I said repeat a lie enough
and you'll get people to believe it and
that's what they do with their
monovalent so-called aid Islamic experts
who have more in common with Isis and
the KKK these hearts void a mercy and
love just joining any hate parade we
know that hundreds of thousands of
innocent people have died just in a few
years in Syria Palestine Burma and the
list goes on and innocent people
continue dying in these countries each
and every day look it up and see what's
going on but there is little mention of
it in the media or none at all it's not
good for business nor do the American
people know no wall-to-wall coverage to
let the world know of these atrocities
we also have college university
shootings mega killings here each and
every day but it's quick news that
quickly goes away except when it has to
do with Muslims and Islam then it's 24
hours wall-to-wall coverage each and
every day never going away anytime
innocent life is lost it's an atrocity
that we all should condemn wherever it
may be I want to talk to those who call
themselves Muslim and remind them that
your prophet muhammad sallallahu alayhi
wasallam who was a prophet for all of
mankind he warned you about going to
extreme for being extremely ignorant in
your Dean from abandoning salah prayer
from abandoning giving in church and
from being the best neighbor he told you
you can rise up to the highest levels of
Jenna by having the best manners in
character helping to change the world
for the better and not by spreading
corruption and hate he warned you from
going to extremes in your religion and
always to choose the middle path make
tawba to Allah but don't remain ignorant
or Dean thinking you're going to get an
easy ride bringing that gangster stuff
and mentality into Islam you just made
toba hamdulillah you left off wine strip
clubs gambling and all immorality but
now you want to skip sitting at the feet
of the scholars and really learning your
Dean you read a few books became an
overnight share making your own fat was
young pumped up a naive you want to go
fight you think you're brave again
bringing that fake gangster man
tality into the Dean you can't even wake
up for fudger go and help clean up your
neighborhood connect with the people
share with them your food and their
right to know Islam be of the best of
manners and character try to make the
world a better place or at least keep
people safe from your harm for our
brothers and sisters in humanity please
don't fall for the false media hype and
don't be like ignorant fools or
harboring poisonous feelings infecting
people with toxic hate quoting quranic
verses or hadith out of context with a
malevolent agenda you'll see when you
take a sincere even-handed approach that
these violent crimes against humanity
have nothing to do with islam because
islam condemns it again if you're
sincere and you want to know the truth
go ahead and do your research now why is
this happening you see this is a
geopolitical thing like when the
Catholic Christian rra the Irish
Republican Army were just killing and
blowing everything up they wanted
political freedom from the United
Kingdom and viewed their land Ireland
was illegally invaded occupied and
illegitimate Lee ruled by the British
they had a political grievance but did
we blame all of Christians for all the
terror they had imposed just because
someone screams Allah ugh but god is
great before doing a crime doesn't make
them legit the same way the notorious
Pablo Escobar would cross himself up
with the Trinity before he murdered
terrorize and raise hell killing
thousands of innocent people and others
exactly like him who might not scream
god is great but suddenly they were
throwing up the three-point cross as
Andrew relic and the Crusaders did so
again we don't blame all Christianity
because the actions of the KKK nor all
us Americans because of an atomic bomb
nor all Jews because of the radical
extreme Zionists who are perpetrating
terrorism and anti-semitism against
Palestinians who are somatic to remember
terrorism has no faith and knows no
boundaries Jews Christians and Muslims
all people of other faiths need to work
together collaborate together in
goodness to create an atmosphere of
understanding and love and not
please subscribe to the dvo follow us on
our official facebook and twitter pages
in the links below please also help
support the V show by making a donation
in the link below